double feuille de fausse garde un geste
précis presque chirurgicale clio noire
scalpel pinceaux avec minutie pierre et
neuf ses livres issus de sa bibliothèque
personnelle
un travail mené depuis quelques années
pour restaurer sa collection de 250
ouvrages on met un carton de couverture
que vous voyez là on fait des coutures
de l'ensemble de l'ensemble des coûts
luc couture de cahiers on les relit
ensemble et après on a dit on fait
l'habillage de la libre dont l'habillage
du livre ça consiste à là par exemple
j'ai des 2000 dos en cuir et papiers
edwards reste en papier avec des coins
cuir réparer protéger en délire la
reliure est considérée comme un art
depuis les romains ce savoir faire
ancestral peut désormais se pratiquer en
atelier comme ici au centre alfred de
vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux sous
l'oeil attentif de juliette les élèves
s'appliquent à suivre les différentes
étapes faut savoir qu'un livre on a à
peu près 40 opérations différentes
on monte les couvertures on coule vivre
sur un couloir
donc on recourt tout le livre on leur
colle
je pense qu'il faut être un petit peu
patient un petit peu soigneux l'après de
la précision parce que sa demande
quand même quelque chose pour que la
culture soit bien bien serré tout le
monde peut faire de largeur j'aime ou
j'aime bien le matelas matière le papier
la peau
moi je veux lui donner une autre vie à
une couverture avec du décor
éventuellement la reliure est une
activité proposée depuis cinq ans par le
centre en moyenne 10 à 15 heures de
travail sont nécessaires pour faire un
livre un véritable patrimoine transmis
tous les mardis à voisins le bretonneux